-Welcome back to "Late Night."
A lot of stories come across
my desk that I have absolutely
no interest in addressing --
meaningless headlines in a sea
of important news.
But one of my writers thinks
that shouldn't stop you from
having to listen to them,
and I guess sometimes,
we just need a distraction,
so here's a new segment
called "Stories Only
Dina Deems Important."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Seth, I'm going to get right
into it.
No time for pleasantries.
I was scrolling through
my curated newsfeed
and came across this article.
"Cockroach sex has taken
a strange turn."
Now, you may have bristled
at that headline
or just read something else,
but get this.
When a male cockroach wants to
mate with a female cockroach,
he will scoot his butt
toward her, open his wings,
and offer her a homemade meal.
[ Light laughter ]
The meal he makes for her
is made of
the two best ingredients --
a mix of sugars and fats.
And as the female cockroach
nibbles her meal,
the male locks on to her
with one penis
while another penis
delivers a sperm package.
[ Laughter ]
Seth?
-What? No!
[ Laughter ]
Don't "Seth" me. I don't want
to be a part of this.
I didn't want to be a part of it
before, and now that I know
what it's about, definitely no.
-Fine, let's just recap here.
Before the male cockroach
even approaches the woman,
he makes her dinner.
He cooks for her.
Then the male roach offers up,
not one, but two penises.
[ Laughter ]
And if everything goes smoothly,
guess how long he can go?
-I couldn't tell you.
It has never even crossed
my mind.
-Around 90 minutes.
[ Audience ohs ]
Yeah. You know what lasts 90
minutes in bed with a human man?
-I don't.
-Neither do I!
[ Laughter ]
Seth, look at this video.
Look how tenderly and sweetly
the male cockroach
treats the woman.
[ Laughter ]
This is my favorite part.
True intimacy.
-Dina, we get it.
But, like, what's the problem
or, like, the point here?
-Well, because of the pesticides
we humans use,
many female cockroaches
have lost their taste
for the sweet stuff
the males make,
and that could change
how they mate and multiply.
-Yeah, but wouldn't that be
a good thing for us?
Less roaches?
-You're missing the point, Seth.
If the female cockroach doesn't
pick up what the male cockroach
puts down,
she's not sticking around.
She's out.
No couples therapy,
no writing sappy letters
or texts to each other.
No one hovering,
checking in from time to time
with an obscure picture
of that trip you both took
to the Berkshires and got so
buzzed you forgot
where you parked the car.
She doesn't have time for that.
If the female cockroach isn't
getting exactly what she wants,
she is done.
For good.
Seth?
-Was that a question
or a cry for help?
Dina, what are you trying
to tell --
-Ladies!
Ladies, ladies, ladies.
We have to be more like
these female cockroaches.
If he's not giving you exactly
what you want,
you need to let him go.
Maybe --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look, maybe if we were treated
like female cockroaches
and got what we deserved,
we'd live forever, too.
So next time you see a roach
in your studio apartment
above Penn Station,
don't scream.
Just take a moment to think,
"Maybe we can learn to be more
like them."
Knowing your worth means getting
what you want.
No bull [bleep].
Just like the female cockroach.
Now, Seth?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now back to you, Seth --
for real this time.
-All right, well, Dina --
wait, did you say this story
came across
your curated newsfeed?
-I'm Dina, and yes, these are
the stories I deem important!
Tune in next week when
I break down why vegan shellfish
live a long, fulfilling life.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]